notre seat du vendredi soir avec Julien
Bourque analyste politique principale à
l'Institut climatique du Canada et
Philippe Gachon de Lucam directeur du
réseau inondation intersectorielle du
Québec messieurs bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous pour
parler d'un sujet très important il y a
des gens qui nous ont dit à vous parler
d'inondation vous connaissez au
changement climatique est-ce qu'on a
tord de faire ça bon d'abord il va
falloir prendre les statistiques pour
voir s'il y a vraiment quelque chose de
notamment d'exceptionnel je pense que
oui juste pour mettre en contexte on a
un printemps qui est particulier cette
année on a eu des sauts évidemment de
température mais juste dans le contexte
on a depuis les 70 dernières années les
températures maximum dans le sud du
Québec
ont augmenté entre 1,5 et 2 degrés
les précipitations ont augmenté
également à peu près de l'ordre de 20 à
70 mm pour tout le printemps et surtout
ce qui est problématique surtout dans le
corps qui nous qui nous intéresse c'est
que les intensités augmentent et en
particulier des extrêmes donc il va
falloir analyser justement cet événement
là si ça s'inscrit encore une fois dans
cette tendance mais définitivement il y
a un réchauffement qui est majeur au
Québec qui s'inscrit d'ailleurs dans un
réchauffement global on s'entend tous
mais qui est plus marqué en particulier
au Québec au printemps que dans d'autres
régions du monde par exemple quels sont
les facteurs qui permettent de faire un
lien avec le réchauffement de la planète
pour vous monsieur Bourke parce qu'il a
été mentionné je pensais beaucoup au
niveau des précipitations dans ce cas-ci
c'est des hivers qui sont plus courts
des précipitations qui sont davantage en
pluie qu'en neige donc ce qui fait en
sorte que les sols sont en mesure
d'absorber l'eau la neige qui font aussi
davantage qui amène plus de débits donc
c'est ce genre de choses là qu'on voit
qui qui se produisent à travers le
Québec le Bureau d'assurance du Canada
quand on regarde les chiffres
d'assurance on voit que ça a quand même
pas mal augmenté il dit aussi qu'il y a
une personne sur cinq qui vit en zone
inondable exposait à des inondations
possibles un million 700 000 propriétés
au Canada comment expliquer qu'on soit
aussi vulnérable aux inondations parce
qu'on s'est construit en grande les
zones pas les cours d'eau au bord des
lacs par exemple dans le cas du Québec à
peu près 83% des municipalités sont
directement ou indirectement affectés
par les inondations donc à différentes
intensités d'accord donc c'est un c'est
beau d'arriver de de se construire après
une rivière on s'est beaucoup construit
évidemment le long des cours d'eau que
soit le Saint-Laurent ou Richelieu par
exemple mais donc on s'est exposé
évidemment aux fluctuations des niveaux
d'eau en se construisant dans les
bassins versants est-ce que c'est ça la
principale menace au bien-être des
citoyens quand on parle de changement
climatique ces inondations là il y a
trois facteurs parce que ce qui explique
notamment les inondations c'est
évidemment l'aléa le fait qu'il y ait
plus d'eau qui tombe et qui va se
évidemment se transformer en
désinondations plus importantes et c'est
la vulnérabilité l'exposition
l'exposition vient d'en parler il y a
beaucoup de municipalités et beaucoup de
gens qui sont construits près de l'eau
mais aussi la vulnérabilité fopolder
parce que la vulnérabilité dans certains
milieux par exemple il y a des endroits
où on l'a Charlevoix avec des pentes
très très abruptes quand tes
précipitations très intenses sont
arrivées il y avait encore à mettre de
neige dans certains secteurs du
Charlevoix donc un ruissellement très
fort des sols gelés donc une
vulnérabilité du milieu qui est
particulière puis il peut y avoir aussi
une vulnérabilité socio-économique si
par exemple un chslb est construit dans
en zone inondable pour évacuer les
populations il va y avoir évidemment
beaucoup plus de dommages directs et
indirects en particulier chez population
âgée que si elles sont pas on va dire
une certaine catégorie qu'elle soit on
va dire socialitairement vulnérable ou
autre il est très clair que l'inaction a
un coût Julien bourg que vous prévoyez
qu'en 2025 les dommages liés au climat
ralentiront la croissance économique du
Canada de 25 milliards de dollars
expliquez-nous absolument ça fait c'est
les inondations et d'autres aléas
climatiques c'est vraiment ce qu'on a vu
le 2025 si on s'entend ce type de main
mais ce qui est plus important mon sens
l'histoire du PIB c'est une partie de
l'histoire et c'est vraiment les
citoyens qui vont payer le plus qui vont
être frappés de différents côtés soit
par l'augmentation des assurances par
exemple quand on part d'inondation ça va
être aussi les réparations qui sont
faites donc les coûts directs qui sont
pas couverts par les inondations on
pense aussi à l'augmentation des taxes
par exemple à mesure que les
gouvernements vont devoir indemniser les
gens vont devoir réparer davantage c'est
aussi une perte de productivité qui
impacte les gens et puis donc c'est
toutes ces choses-là qui font en sorte
que ils se retrouvent à devoir payer
davantage je pense et c'est toutes ces
choses là qui fait en sorte que des
experts comme vous disent il faut
investir il faut investir combien dans
l'adaptation changement climatique il
faut investir beaucoup il faut
certainement investir dans la mesure des
impacts qui nous attendent évidemment
c'est pas seulement les gouvernements
qui vont devoir débourser je pense que
chacun son rôle à jouer puis il faut
aller voir aussi au niveau du privé pour
trouver d'autres façons de nouveaux
modèles économique pour être en mesure
de d'arriver au montant qui ont qu'on a
besoin là pour vraiment éviter le pire
finalement l'adaptation parce qu'on
investit bien sûr pour lutter pour
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre s'adapter c'est vivre avec tout à
fait alors ce qui est important à
retenir ça on n'entend pas suffisamment
parler l'adaptation elle se fait pas sur
des hypothèses elle se fait sur les
connaissances scientifiques et pour ça
il faut mettre des efforts pour
développer ses connaissances
scientifiques je prends un exemple je
suis directeur d'un réseau qui couvre
toutes les universités du Québec on a
besoin la barre de travailler ce genre
d'enjeux interceptorial il faut investir
en recherche former la relève dans une
période justement on a pénurie de la
main d'oeuvre donc assurer on va dire
non seulement le développement des
expertises encore une fois
interceptorielle parce que le problème
il n'est pas juste un problème
météorologique ou idéologique c'est un
problème d'aménagement du territoire de
conséquences sur les populations donc
c'est investi en recherche pour être
capable de développer les connaissances
et en bout de ligne aussi être capable
de développer et de mettre suffisamment
de ressources pour faire le transfert
des connaissances la mobilisation ces
connaissances là notamment vis-à-vis des
Siders que ce soit les municipalités ou
les gouvernements et est-ce qu'on est
dans un modèle essentiellement où on
tout ce qui est aménagement du
territoire les lois et les règlements
qui qui guident les municipalités à
prendre les bonnes décisions c'est aussi
important puis à mon sens c'est pas
nécessairement plus cher mais ce qui est
important c'est définitivement d'éviter
de construire plus de risques donc vous
devez l'information puis de que les gens
prennent les bonnes décisions finalement
que ce soit les gens les municipalités
les entreprises en admettant que les
municipalités puissent manquer de moyens
pour travailler à ça beaucoup de gens se
disent ben là effectivement vous posez
bien la question tantôt qui va payer
est-ce que c'est des hausses de taxes
est-ce que c'est des hausses d'impôts ça
fait partie de l'équation quand même sur
ce qui a à faire c'est clair qu'il faut
mettre à fond en adaptation maintenant
où aller chercher cet argent là je donne
un exemple la bourse du carbone on peut
prendre une partie de pourcentage
justement sur la bourse du carbone les
Coffe c'est de qualité on a parlé
justement avant de rentrer en ondes
c'est une façon aussi d'aller chercher
les ressources et réinvestir en
recherche juste pour terminer aussi là
dessus c'est extrêmement important la
majorité des connaissances scientifiques
sont développées par les universités qui
manquent de ressources à l'heure
actuelle on vient d'ailleurs les
universitaires et les étudiants viennent
de faire une manifestation pour dire
qu'il y avait pas assez de ressources on
a encore des bourses qu'on avait il y a
10 ans on s'entend que le coût de la vie
a augmenté donc investir en recherche et
en adaptation c'est aussi des coûts
qu'on va économiser en futur former les
experts qui vont accompagner non
seulement les municipalités et aussi les
gouvernements et dernière question qui
nous reste beaucoup de temps monsieur
bourg est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il est
clairement devenu risqué de vivre près
d'un cours d'eau je m'achèterai pas une
maison sur le bord d'un cours d'eau
personnellement je pense que oui je
pense qu'il faut faire attention encore
une fois c'est pas partout c'est très
difficile au niveau des rivières par
exemple c'est particulier contrairement
aux côtes qui sont tous un petit peu
plus directs mais je dirais que il faut
s'adapter les endroits où ça fait du
sens économiquement de s'adapter il faut
le faire mais il va falloir commencer à
réfléchir aussi à comment sortir les
gens du risque ça c'est une conversation
qui est un petit peu plus difficile à
voir Julien Bourque Philippe Gachon très
intéressant merci pour cette perspective
ce soir merci d'avoir été à vous pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]